I'm a condom right now 6 7 8 13 14 15
I got pursuing the next 21 22 25 Chinese
twenties I got 27 tattooed it ain't much
compared that other people who keep our
love like a honey first two was this
elephant for the Indians this is like a
cause of fame and fortune and when you
turn it backwards like on another face
and it was no professional tattoo
whatsoever our best friend got in his
hand chatter - we did like basically the
same time he did we got tie this
together and a month after he died he
got killed so I don't even know his will
hurt more or this one in the hand or the
one I got in the back of in the back it
really hurt that's up - I got it my back
is my face and my wife's face basically
[Music]
haven't finished in there's been a whole
year that went by says it takes so much
time yeah I've been letting this lateral
walk I think it was the first picture we
took nobody even we was together I've
told it like laughing but I was serious
about it she thought I was playing and
she was very nice about that I cuz we
was just done she already had guy my my
main tag donors you can tell her what
would I marry you
and so that okay okay
we are got my son's name y'all got my
Baba's doing real good left hand I got
caught this man cut a window always see
it you know everything I do I do it for
my family be his good to always see
their name so I always got an present in
my mind I still gotta do my dad's name
somewhere looking it from that point of
view I'm gonna give my dad my dad's name
to enhance my mom you can tell me she
said she like know what you did she like
the Dragon Ball Z one of the Jesus one
all the dark things you don't like
he says that toppled betta it says
loyalty for life I got this horse rider
with the pyramid on his forehead and I
like this open area before I got big I
just read a lot about therapies all that
I sold in prison basically is when I
started to do a good relationship with
God and I started praying a lot I read
the Bible a lot so I started to get a
lot of knowledge long life so that's why
I got very married she's crying but I
like blood and here I got Jesus faith is
all like with the shape of all the
brothers
Jesus with the crown before he got
crucified I like this this is my
favorite tattoo the Chicago boy on top
it says RFP Jesus because that was my
best friend I was his name and it got
the day that he was born and the day
that he died me and his brothers any all
kind of the same sensible I wish he was
able me like the most meaningful one is
dead one basically I got the Maybach
logo here cuz when I first got signed it
was to Rick Ross as the Maybach Music
logo so that was just a moment on my
life basically it wasn't like I don't
regret it but I wish I had another thing
there so like a mother in the neck in
the neck I got here the god of chops in
here said well I fell on one day this
heart was like my little kid on earth so
here that Goku tatted this happen had
the Super Saiyan do you go and live that
the black Goku and yeah guy go to but
this ain't finished though the day I was
getting this one I was like yeah I was
tired already because at the time I
think isn't Vegeta I got to put this on
him I can't wait to see the whole I'm
trying to go all around it I want to
have the whole back cover sometimes I
want to get tatted something in my face
really little but other time like back
in my face
basically they'll hold all their own I'm
I get excited the whole bag I was
thinking like when I came out I wanted
to keep shining my shape in my stomach
just um I got hurt a lot so I still got
it
[Music]